não vamos falar demasiado os números
apesar da minha vida ser muito centrado
em ambos o economista em suas torno do
dia a dia mas hoje vamos falar do valor
acrescentado da inclusão e em concreto
do inclusive crime que foram lançados em
2017 com a nova ciclovia sandy
finalmente e sobre os objetivos
decidisse forma inversa iniciativa e
queria explicar isso em três andamentos
diferentes sempre lugar a partir de uma
história pessoal tem a minha história é
para para mostrar como é que chegamos
até esta iniciativa em segundo lugar das
contas o que pretendemos com o inclusive
emitir fórum e em seu lugar retirar
algumas implicações para que o que é
nossa vida em comunidade
o essa história todas as iniciativas
começam a partir de uma história e esta
não é diferente esta história é é uma
história que a minha mas também é da
minha família da minha canon e dos
nossos filhos é a história da nossa
sumiu e que nos leva até o ponto em que
estamos agora ea iniciativa que estamos
a lançar nós há cinco anos se virmos a
adotar é o nosso quinto filho
nós tínhamos quatro filho ea cerca de 70
anos lançamos nessa decisão e há cinco
anos em maio vai pra nossa casa
o renato tem hoje oito anos até me deter
9 ronaldo o nosso em fio é mais novo que
é nossa quarta filha cerca de um mês uma
regra nas ações quando já se tem filhos
que o filho adotado seja mais novo eo
mais novo para nos procurar uma certa
hierarquia familiar
yonath nossa casa há cerca de cinco anos
em maio
e quando o show é uma das primeiras
coisas que fizemos foi diagnosticar os
problemas de saúde que o que o
governador tinha em e foi apresentado
que o bernardo tem 99% de incapacidade
portanto quando visto por uma junta
médica que é o nível de incapacidade de
governar tem
em não sendo por não ver é totalmente c
não fala não andava hoje começa a andar
e comunique de forma muitíssimo imitava
é é atualmente romário deverá fazer três
quatro palavras 34 sons que significam
diferentes coisas e nós entretenhamos de
uma forma bastante clara
bernardo que mexeu sem qualquer tipo de
problema foi vítima de maus tratos
quando era sem machismo passou a ter
este grau de incapacidade de 99% e
chegou a nossa casa a 50 cm entre os na
nossa na nossa família e é o nosso
quinto filho a nossa história com
granada uma história muito boa e aquilo
que tem acontecido ao longo destes cinco
anos e extraordinariamente positivo que
era pra nós e queremos acreditar também
por nada tem sido uma história muito
positiva de enorme inspiração de enorme
valor acrescentado muito mais que um
evento em qualquer família e em qualquer
é em qualquer família com um filho é uma
história feita de desafios de questões
de titulados e esta também é uma
história com dúvidas com questões com
temas com interrogações que era nos
outros nosso próprio filho tem 16 anos e
14 6 e 8 que era também no canadá
e estas intervenções ou um destes cinco
anos em maio que surgiu ideia desta
iniciativa do inclusive que me falou que
todos estes cinco anos em muitas
circunstâncias foram os tucanos
perguntas vinculadas dúvidas
relativamente ao ronaldo ea sua condição
e as suas de efetuadas que em muitas
circunstâncias parece que não tinham
nenhuma resposta prévia e era ao e que
era mim ter a carne nos intrigava
muitíssimo perante uma dúvida iremos à
procura da resposta e parece que nunca
ninguém tinha estado na mesma situção
antes nós o que fazemos na escola como é
que o henry tipo de escolas em que
existe aí deve passar primeiro ano
quando fizer seis anos é melhor ficar
é pra ele tem temos viram um clube de
eventos como estes faz não existe de
forma muito clara e muitas vezes porém
algumas destas questões nos
perguntávamos como é que é possível que
estas perguntas não estejam já
respondidas não estejam mais acessíveis
seguramente não somos os primeiros a ter
este tipo de titulados e começarmos
sempre alguma destas questões nos 10 com
cala é verdade que fomos resolvendo é
velada em todas as circunstâncias
percebemos que antes nós outros já
tinham tido o mesmo problema e eu tenho
ido resolver com mais ou menos
dificuldade com mais ou menos
intensidade
mexer para encontrar as soluções muitas
vezes temos por conhecer muitas dessas
funções foram encontradas por conhecemos
muita gente temos mais capacidade mais
recurso e portanto com dois ou três
cinemas com um conhecimento único com
alguém consciente fomos resolvendo essas
situações poço foram com o canto mas
como coxinhas e clara perante situações
semelhantes a outras pessoas
em outras circunstâncias têm seguramente
muita dificuldade em resolver em navegar
neste ambiente nem pressão nos depois
num chute e viu muitas vezes encontramos
soluções à sua medida
meus poucos calava as muitas pessoas que
resolver o problema do seu filho que
numa associação pequenina numa
determinada geografia foram encontrando
as suas funções e muito bem tal como nós
em que alimentamos a procura em primeira
instância da função para o nosso filho
bernardo e essa é a nossa primária
primeira vez que um sonho a surgir a
idéia é porque nós não tentávamos
contribuíram também para a comunidade e
a partir das dúvidas que nós próprios
estamos tendo e nos procurando resolver
procurar e identificar soluções possam
ser palavras possam ser estruturais que
quando alguém se depara pronto mesmo
tipo de problema possa ter uma solução
foi testada estado comentava que pode
ser aplicada e que em vez de termos 50
soluções diferentes em muitos sítios que
passássemos a ter escala que passássemos
a textura
passaremos a ter idéias que funcionam
tanto estados e podem ser organizadas
para a investida é procurarmos encontrar
alguém pudesse ser nosso parceiro
percebemos desde muito cedo que não é
possível sermos nós sozinhos ou com
amigos ou com pessoas que conhecemos a
fazer isto é de forma autônoma e fomos
ter com novas tecnologias ambientalmente
que prometemos as pessoas doha porque
temos boas relações porque sentimos nova
um espírito empreendedor um espírito
contribuir o espírito queria fazer a
diferença e colocarmos a nova um desafio
foi vocês estão disponíveis para em
conjunto conosco lançar uma iniciativa
procura identificar as barreiras uma
maior inclusão de pessoas com
deficiência na comunidade evento ficará
funções
algumas delas que é hoje funcionam
preciso ver como podem ser salvas e
depois testá-las de um modo prático no
terreno e isso funcionar em escalar
essas funções e é nova diz nos forma
muito clara estamos disponíveis para
isso e assim lançarmos em setembro de
2017 ou inclusive filme foram está é
inserido é nova s b que tem neste
momento três pessoas a trabalhar a full
time e que o pretende fazer é exatamente
isto e identificar barreiras a inclusão
de pessoas com deficiência na comunidade
encontrar soluções chá hoje possam
existir apesar de ser uma escala mais
pequena é k ou internacionalmente ea
partir dessas funções talas no treino e
depois cloud
este é o objetivo do inclusive que o
ministro informa o que vamos fazer
então vamos fazer como jorge enes é um
centro de estudos em um laboratório de
idéias porque o laboratório de idéias
nós não temos
apesar de estarmos numa popular e é bom
estarmos numa popular porque foi um lado
está habituado é investigar é perceber
as causas subjacentes aos problemas é
ser rigorosa na forma como propõem as
soluções também foi popular é um sítio
para fazer isto nós não temos 31 deus
teórico
queremos testá los no território temos
vergonha disse massa
ps essa trabalhar conosco ea câmara de
cascais disponibilizou-se para ser um um
território de teste e portanto muitas
das soluções que temos a identificar
vamos testá los andes caixa eles
funcionarem vamos depois ao orgasmo
a idéia é promover uma comunidade
bastante mais inclusiva e é muito bom
poder um serviço do ame de nova com
cinco mil alunos e professores porque
isso também aumenta ou hérnias para este
tipo de problemas
vamos encarar é no efetivo identificar
um problema e procurar que combinado
educativa da nova alunos professores e
alunos de mestrado e empresas que estão
associadas a outros se debruce sobre
esse problema e procura encontrar uma
solução preço problema
temos um conjunto leiriense está em
outras têm juntado ao projeto e
lançarmos em setembro como jogos disse
estamos agora de uma forma mais intensa
é trabalhar o tema do primeiro ano o
tema do 1º ano é o emprego
tínhamos várias hipóteses mas num
contexto do epr o sistema da nova com
tantas empresas na nova s/b a participar
no novo campus
entendemos que o primeiro tema poderia
ser sempre de levar pessoas com
deficiência
como é que nós podemos contribuir para
que mais pessoas tenham consciência
possam ter emprego para não ficar
completamente fora dos números e eu só
dizer passando aqui muito rapidamente
alguns quadros que a taxa de desemprego
das pessoas com deficiência ea equipe
emendou duas vezes a taxa de desemprego
de pessoas sem deficiência
o emprego um desemprego de adoção e é
muito mais eu vá do que as pessoas
sentem assim porque é difícil muitas
destas pessoas é ter em conseguirem uma
vaga mas isso não é mais elevado por
duas razões porque muitas dessas pessoas
estão primeiro instrumento de informação
e portanto não contam bastante distinta
e muitas dessas pessoas não querem
sequer tentar empregar-se portanto há
aqui uma dificuldade enorme este é neste
tema é algo que claramente percebido em
múltiplas circunstâncias
portanto é um problema importante
tipicamente negligenciado e com enormes
externalidades negativas o que dói
evento ficamos como os principais
obstáculos à empregabilidade de pessoas
com deficiência
três temas diferentes em primeiro lugar
em muitas circunstâncias
em muitos casos as próprias pessoas com
deficiência ou suas famílias não querem
estar empregadas
há muita resistência própria procurar
emprego porque muitas vezes têm medo do
que vai encontrar tem se medo não ser
integrado tem se medo não se conseguir
tem se medo que não lhes facilitem a
vida portanto muita gente e não tentasse
que é importante não tenha predisposição
para procurar emprego
do outro lado do mercado como diria o
pita barros as empresas muitas vezes não
estão sequer ware para este tema não tem
sequer uma predisposição para dizer eu
posso recrutar pessoas com deficiência e
eu tenho um contato 60 ou no pôster
pessoas com deficiência motora sem
qualquer tipo do problema mas é verdade
é que muitas empresas não estão
despertos para isso não se colocaram
nesse plano e entra em seu lugar é que
mesmo quando a prostituição quem procura
emprego e de quem tem vagas de emprego
os mecanismos de se encontrarem com os
outros 11 com o outro não existem
nós quando estamos numa empresa e
precisamos de alguém para uma
determinada vaga
vimos uma empresa de recrutamento e
seleção que nos encontre tem idade
as empresas de recrutamento e seleção
não estão no mercado é considerar
pessoas com deficiência não apresentam
esses candidatos às empresas e às vezes
não apresentam ser porque têm uma
perceção que a empresa não vai querer
considerar o pranto candidate com o
mesmo tipo de capacidade não querem
tomar o risco de rolar uma pessoa com
deficiência
portanto vemos problemas não só cinco
candidatos nem existência de vagas mesmo
muito
no mexe nem existência deste mercado na
capacidade por exemplo fazer um
currículo de explicar que a capacidade
que o time precisar ter algumas em
capacidade nem capacidade de uma empresa
descrever uma função de uma forma que
seja perceptível tentar procura de
emprego por fazer aquela função só
cantar luz visto estamos a fazer dois
programas o piloto pinheiro eo tcheco
foi inteligente
são dois pilotos neste momento no píer
temos dez pessoas tenham consciência e
dez alunos finalistas da nova estão a
viver em conjunto o processo de
abordagem ao mercado de trabalho para
arranjar emprego estão a trabalhar em
conjunto com os protótipos empregos
outro para o tipo mas é porque o mesmo
processo a ser escritos ao mesmo tempo a
treinar em fazer entrevistas é
beneficiar do gabinete de plasma de nova
e de cooperação celebrados nas empresas
para que elas tenham mais confiança mais
capacidade saibam como se apresentar às
empresas
estamos a fazer com empresas concurso
mande um programa chamado e já foi
inclusive em em que procuramos é que as
empresas de recursos humanos que têm
hoje o processo de recrutamento muito
robustos incluam nesse processo de
recrutamento os a data em usa justa e na
medida do necessário por serrão com esse
avalia esse tipo de candidatos para que
possam incluir na sua na sua dinâmica
diária é o recrutamento de pessoas com
deficiência
este programa tem tido uma enorme
procura de algumas das maiores empresas
portuguesas têm juntavam inclusive
filmes e foram para poderem os próprios
participar mistura explicado está o o o
que é inclusive um minuto foram queria
terminar com uma nota de um ano de
frangos e voltar a minha experiência
pessoal ea experiência da nossa família
como podem ver a lógica é primária do
inclusive filme fórum é procurar
contribuir para melhorar a vida das
pessoas com deficiência e para que elas
estejam mais incluídas mais acolhidas na
comunidade mas a verdade é que os
objetivos
uma iniciativa como esta não se esgotam
nessa tentativa de contribuir para que a
vida das pessoas com deficiência gemendo
e de fato
voltando à nossa história o nosso filho
bernardo com 99 por cento de
incapacidade
o nosso investir em cinco anos é que o
valor acrescentado jornalismo para a
comunidade em que está inserido é
absolutamente extraordinário o primeiro
transformador de 99% em que precisava
nem comunidade então sincera é
absolutamente extraordinário e no mundo
em que privilegiamos quem correr mais
rápido quem é mais inclusivo quem toca é
melhor quem é o professor quem tem as
melhores capacidades e em que
valorizamos e vem
todas essas capacidades e as flores
centavo é que o tempo nos deixaram o
poder transformador de 99 por cento de
incapacidade e até o momento
a mudança que vemos na nossa família e
na escola do campeonato está na
comunidade em que o sincero naquilo que
eu tenho conseguido fazer a razão de ser
de uma iniciativa como esta é ativada
pelos 99 por cento de incapacidade ou
seja em inclusão de pessoas com
deficiência na comunidade eu e antes
mais um enorme valor a acrescentar para
com ela é nossa comida melhor souberam
zagueiro booth ciara e trazer para nossa
e havia as pessoas com deficiência e com
mais em capacidade não e valorizando os
99% tem capacidade mas valorizando muito
cento trazem que ignoram no seu poder
transformador não valorizando que não
conseguem fazer nos valorizar muito em
cima que o conseguem contribuir por isso
desafios do show é que uma maior e
melhor inclusão de pessoas com
deficiência na comunidade não é um
desafio apenas para essas pessoas e para
a xuxa ganhou este é um desafio que é
bom nós porque foi usada não estudamos a
família onde estamos
as escolas onde andamos
seguramente em hora se forem mais
inclusivas destas pessoas porque o seu
poder transformador é muito superior à
que é o que os números podem parecer
obrigado suas palestras inspiradora
deixa uma dúvida este exercitar ser
feito na nova é único ou existe outros
outras iniciativas semelhantes em outros
países
não eu acredito que haja nós para já não
não não identificar mas também nos
preocupamos muito em fazer isso mas
temos preocupados em cada um destes
temas nomeadamente emprego irá em
entender o que está a ser feito no
otimismo relativamente à empregabilidade
e vemos muita coisa acontecer noutros
países sobre empregabilidade em termos
oficiais
[Aplausos]